je suis pas venu seul je suis venu
accompagnée de mon adolescente préférée
ça va maman
tu es content d'être avec moi
on va manger on va manger
[Musique]
que j'ai taillé dans une petite bûche
cette nuit dans un petit morceau de bois
on a la montagne il y en a plein pour la
Saint-Valentin
c'est la clé de mon cœur qui va avec
voilà
donc allez je vais rentrer parce que il
faut non non non allez on y va oh là là
faut les skier ouh
yes
ça va trop bien un homme il a plus
d'expérience plus de maturité et en plus
de ça comme il s'est déjà éclaté quand
il était jeune et ben il est beaucoup
plus calme avec toi parce qu'en fait il
a déjà fait toutes ces erreurs de
jeunesse voilà
une fois par semaine c'est déjà bien
sportif pour moi mais tu as